What if you could go back in time and change something? You can change anything you want. What would it be?
Dust yourself up and move on to the next one. I don't want the next one and why do you even care bro, look at you?
You're a tall good looking dude and could probably have any girl in this bar.
You know, maybe I failed to properly explain to you the boss employee relationship.
I tell you what to do and you do it.
You help rich people get richer. It's like teaching fish how to swim. You are really smart.
You'd be doing something more with life. You know, it's not too late to do something. Great
Wow this girl is really gotten into you. I don't know what I'm doing. Help me help me.
You only have two options. Okay, one winner the old-fashioned way with your words or (I let her be.)
You kill her boyfriend. Cal you crazy?
I need you apologize because I should have told you that I had a boyfriend
I don't want to look back on this moment and think why didn't I go after it? I don't want any regret.
Time travel it is in fact something that may become a reality. Why didn't you continue your research?
A man can only handle so much failure.
I need you to send me back in time to a point before she meets this guy?
She's with now that she thinks she's in love with.
I can't send you back. Look these equations. They're still unsolved.
So unless you could solve them. Ya you know what, lets just give up, right? We keep trying. That's what we do. That's what we've been doing! We don't give up!
(Yelling... We just keep trying!! I'm telling you it's just not possible!)
I actually envy you, You envy the guy that's in love with the girl he can't have? I envy the guy who knows what he wants and
Isn't afraid to go after it.
This this lifelong quest that I was on was actually about something else altogether.
What are you doing here?
May the force be with you.
Ally?
Do I know you?